ci sono i laser che si muovono dobbiamo
riuscire a sorpassarlo sempre di feriti
con visioni imposti morta
oggi dovremmo scappare la prigione
maschi contro femmine
maschi o femmine mi vedevi commenti
secondo voi se vincerò io o se vincerò
vita sono brutti brutta sarà una super è
che il professor entusiasmate quindi vi
consiglio di prendere i pop corn
qualcosa da mangiare qualcosa di ieri
mettervi comodi comodi lasciate un verme
piace questo e iniziamo subito alla
nostra è pronto e jorge riuscirei ad
uscire di prigione prima io di vita l'ha
subito perché una super mega tipo veloce
dice gradi per questo qua
certo avventura che ci sta spingendo
dall'altra pallamano che volevo andare
di qua l'ho già superato dynamic e
dobbiamo passare fa da questi tubi
dentro c'è problema il capitolo scrive
abbraccia ellera vita alta le vincerà
questa volta non vedo l'ora di vedere
tutti gli espressa e lavezzi di vitale
gol facendo giocare in questi bottoni
per scavare il fosso a un clik clik così
riusciamo a scappare qua sotto attento a
non cadere qua sotto o
il successo raro che vita e non ti
ancora fretta a segno che non dico
niente sono già avanti ortane devo
raggiungere ma vediamo che cosa che
dobbiamo nuotare in queste fognature
ok per la barca andare con la barca no
no
sono fatti superare vantaggio deve
vincere il team rosa femmine story radio
blu sarebbe tantissimo mi ha superato
proprio saltare sono un bravissimo
nuotatore
pazienza ci sono le guardie qui da
quelli sono i costumi che ti troverò la
superato lo sono inventato occhi
successo dobbiamo attraversare la strada
molto più a buttare molto molto attenti
a non essere spiaccicati dalle mani
delle macchine della polizia un aiuto
corri
c'è mancato poco mi stavo per prendere
il peccato che abitano questa mi ha
toccato
a me fa scappare da questa prigione
tranne vitale guarda come corre
velocemente veniamo a seccare ha
raggiunto i loro di questa prigione
diverso ha superato vitale c è grande
sono caduto di nuovo che bisogna saltare
sulla carta igienica smetta di non
andare troppo avanti altrimenti vinci to
and fro finita ma no mi sono spiaccicata
mio teletrasportato quale
anch'io vitale la gente ti ha superato
non sospettano niente presto continuiamo
ad andare scappiamo perfetto il piano
malefico funziona
muro si è sfracellato proprio di provini
talento però bisogno sfracellato nello
stesso punto tuo è fatto distrarre dalla
ciambella di la verità è vero sembra che
si stia mente quando davvero no non
riesco a passare questo stesso
vada avanti così tu però vita mi dà
retta continuando a sfracellarsi
lanciata domenica
almeno e morbido novità né arrivato da
joe basta salire le scale per prendere
poi la settore tanto qualche adrai
10.000 volte sono in altissimo dove sei
non riesco più trovarti lievi di pietro
dall'altro quel vantaggio
qualcuno si è sfracellato non capisco mi
sono stretti per fortuna si poteva
salvare qua non devo ricominciare tutto
da capo però già livello di taffeta
invece evitare a livello di ruby mi
hanno dovuto dire un equilibrio non
credere qua adesso lo devo andare qui
tale mi sta raggiungendo
sto continuando a salire ma ho fatto
siamo in al troppo ho paura di cadere a
tentare almeno salvato acqua per fortuna
dove sei
mi dispiace non mia giunta non ha mai
come devo fare a salina le sopra
della di casa porta fatta
finalmente sono arrivato qua
qui posso salvare se non cado prima e
sono caduto adesso dove devo andare
l'uso più
no tutto da capo mentre evitare linke
strato io continuo andare allo stage 20
tale face 12 9 giu ma sì tu quella c'è
scritto fili donuts prima che se ne
andiamo che è davvero un aspetto fa usa
credo sono caduta in una trappola e non
avremo l'avvocato per
scadere vitali andare a prendere donna
ma non riesco a superare questo face
comunque sono dietro l'idea tanto ora
accadrà in nella trappola dei donandoni
ovvero me ne sono accorto sono già
passato
si può caduti entrambi ma perché così di
peggio è caduta ed
è piano piano devo prendere la rincorsa
bene
non vorrei dire ma sono stato rinominato
beata e ho una brutta notizia si dice
che dobbiamo fare un buco nel nel bagno
per poter scappare nel bagno
bisogna stare sulla carta igienica
ricavi netti ma che razza di ski from
frenata sono è una prigione e ci ho
passato in vantaggio un ciclo
aspettami non vedo più non mollare amico
mi dice il mio amico prigioniero piano
piano equilibrio equilibrio culto segno
appunto 6 avanti restano al livello 22
davvero io sono ancora al 15 com'è
possibile ma no in realtà stavo
guardando i punti che come stage io sono
state 17
16 ed il prezzo
sembra super mario
con i blocchetti
l'importante è che ora le femmine sono
in vantaggio
no sono caduto
c'è uno stuzzicante mi qualcuno si è
spiaccicata non sono io spirito vitale
fatto sui blocchetti
c'è qualche prigioniero ecuador e
sprigionerà detto che stanno arrivando
li ha sentiti arrivare dal tunnel pretto
tappo nell'ottava sono arrivato lombardi
è fantastica davvero bellissimo le
prigioni sono sempre super divertenti
ora dobbiamo moltiplicarsi perché stanno
arrivando a quella sei tu
vitale è già arrivato come hai fatto a
fare progetti
per dire molto semplice ho smesso di
spray allarmi però in realtà non mi sono
appena sfracellato di nuovo è
impossibile che vitale fumettista
siamo riusciti a uscire è vero se vuoi
il tuo elicottero ci sono e le voltano
sinistra di contro un elicottero altro
panero video guide unione vuole far
pagare con i robot
vediamo se questo devo pagarlo
andare a piedi
il vantaggio vitale mi ha superato nel
solito sono già un livello più dovevo
vincere team femmine pa diventa sempre
più complicato creerà perché c'è questo
che gira ok io un trucco basta
inseguirlo vero invece di scappare e un
ottimo del greco non dovevo dire che mi
ha truccato dietro di te
attenzione al nostro show della tv
italiana ha superato ma senza sono fiero
di te perché stiamo andando nella banca
casa siamo nella banca adesso che
dobbiamo fare guarda stanno rapinando la
banca e dal soffitto vedi si può per
usciti di galera perché adesso dobbiamo
rientrare
c'è scritto aiutami a rubare queste cose
sappiamo ok da perfetti ladri attentato
siamo diventati velocissimi e bravissimi
che il rombo più o meno però vi
ricordate i primi gameplay
quante volte ci sforzavamo soprattutto e
vitale e vero ci sono i no perché si
muovono dobbiamo riuscire a sopportarli
sempre di fare tipo mission impossible
questo continua a scongelarsi e volevo
solo dirti questo almeno si muovono
lentamente si accetta attento a tutto
questo difficile
anch'io che sono delle patatine fritte
questa oro con diamante un rubino e
questo giorno senza fine bolloso
zafferano
attenta che qui c'è la lava può
diventare la nota perché bisogna
sbrigarsi questa compaiono e scompaiono
super difficile difficilissimo bisogna
andare veloci ai temi bisogna trovare il
momento giusto per saltare sotto
no è difficilissimo
che bisogna rimanere in quelli più alti
e aspettare questo stage è davvero
difficile ci siamo schiacciati 10.000
voce bisogna avere un sacco di partenza
è passare solo a merano piano quando
tiri atto non quelli piccolini
è veramente difficile insomma sembra un
livello di supermario e indovina chi è
in vantaggio adesso sono un po ma
ce l'ho fatta visto nostran serata chigi
mi ha molto ma ce l'ho fatta allora
questo charter abbiamo un muro laser
quindi bisogno di donne temi non sembra
entry gran vitone rosa e blu di qua
non mi freghi ma dove mourinho no si
sono azionate gli allarmi dobbiamo
scappare prima di essere circondate via
grotta mi ricordano della polizia sono
ci sono inseguimento quindi tocca a
scappare di mano
attenzione perché questi strani ma è
difficilissimo
molto
scompaiono pure dopo un po scompaiono
quindi bisogna stare
e troppo le cose che
proviamo da questa parte
io provo a fare il giro qua forse è
meglio andare su quelli che non
scompaiono non ci creda se riprese
riuscita
allora partiamo un po più di rincorsa si
è meglio andare in quelle che non
scompaiono
[Musica]
a tentare anche gli ultimi scompaio
acque
casa indovino che il vantaggio non si
credo
non lo fanno o
quello dopo è bellissimo e un ponte sì
ma cadono i pezzi
ma si poteva camminare
non ci cavolo sei troppo furba se in
vantaggio 6
ma non cadono questa macchina della
polizia esistente quando però devo
vincere come fanno queste macchine della
polizia a rimanere sospese ferrario a
farsi un altro stage super mario
alcuni però ho sempre preso i pesi da
questi pro ma
avete lasciato un viaggio adesso di un
mi piace per portar
via voti ha funzionato il vostro mi
piace
o no la barra mi sta inseguendo
questo crolla via qual è quello che
crolla e
o cotone in vantaggio per il momento
odio questo stage ho visto quello che
per ora sono riuscito ad andare avanti
ha superato di nuovo si sono lo stage
successivo mi hai fatto appunto
perché sono troppo bravi ad essere in
vantaggio almeno salvata da superare
mica no mi devi andare piano qui perché
perché pericoloso corato forte quasi
siamo allo stesso punto
ma io sono più avanti
ora ti faccio camino
siamo caduti entrambi vanità che l'unico
modo e collaborare e adesso che potevo
andare quindi di kia wow no questi sono
bellissime diventa sempre più l'aspetto
lente questo parkour
questa era una bella trappola per ora
via via wow è bellissimo per the broom
siamo testa a testa
no io sono con la testa in acqua adesso
non ne dobbiamo scappare con i gommoni
con i gommoni arrivo prodotti hardware
hanno dato gli sono vicino non andrai
lontano senza di me perché parte da
professare che dovrà essere cellulare
prima o poi
spero proprio di no
indovina che il bloccaggio adesso
vediamo tu con te volte accadrà è
soprattutto lì
che sarebbe caduto li ho posto con
caduto di nuovo domani a questa strada
quelle difficili davvero ma anche se
questa si vuole più tempo
non sei molto lontana non devo cadere a
testa non devo chiedere perché no
hai superato
ora devo fare la spesa dei cappelli da
poliziotto abbiamo già allo stage 40
abbiamo fatto ma soprattutto come ho
fatto a superarti adesso
stai attento e
penso che dobbiamo giocare in a1
sfracellato sul laser è sfracellato
anche in acqua salemi ha superato sono
in vantaggio ma di poco
questi ma zero sono complicati perché
caro sempre
ritorno col botto ruolo vitale mi ha
superato
allora cerca di
nuovo così caduta è troppo diventa odio
quarto 6 giu botta ora lo faccio
velocemente e batta
sei riuscita sono quasi
stai attenta a non cadere all'ultimo
ma dove è la prigione europa e alla
prigione delle femmine io sono così a
problemi di ciao da persone della
premier ma quindi vuol dire che noi
femmine stiamo vincendo forse
non direi devo sbrigarmi in italia avuto
davanti
ho scoperto una scorciatoia anche bene
io ti ruberò l'idea
9 scoperta
ok posso faccio io no ma perché caso
ancora devo riuscire a superare questo
fra poco lo scoprirai perché bisogna
stare molto attenti
ok che cos'è successo
guarda
tira miti ma esplodono
etichetta bastano queste borsette delle
pozioni non lo so via manca pochissimo
all'uscita devono raggiungere l'italia
deve uscire prima
io sono di vantaggio o no brett che ci
sono dei laser strani bisogna stare
molto attenti wow sembra veramente di
essere in visioni in primo
piano un piano piano
via
siamo quasi riuscita
ci siamo ecco e l'azzurro sito e vitale
bratt agisce
o no non puoi capire la two day perché
questi ma se evitare cade io vado priva
no
devo fartelo prima io non ne sono sicuro
favi tar e questo sembra un onore un
orologio di lhasa
fermo altro giorno di vico ce la puoi
fare ma anche no sparacello km
2 siamo
timbrata timbrava testa a testa
chi vincerà io per avanti però
eri avanti manca pochissimo
no e mi raccomando stai attenta qui a
non cadere quelle bambini non ci credo
come
sarebbe stato se
tale perché evitare troppo bravo capo
siamo riuscite buona
la prima il finale è lo scenario allora
vogliamo un altare ve lo sigla by nature
volti il primo velocità 50 e autori che
pertanto wow da fare tutta la prigione
lo ha definito locale
avrebbe bird bird david ho saltato su
ricomincia il gioco e quindi mi ha fatto
ricominciare il giornale a vito evitare
di pochi secondi a 9 i troppi tg1 ma se
volete la rivincita alla sua di un bel
mi piace è ora vi lasciamo quattro
casalinghe su cui cliccare per vedere
inoltre altri video cade su quello che
preferite buona visione ciao